It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us for our 134th episode today!
BAU BAU!
It's been a while!
Thank you Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
And I see so many new Ruffians recently too!
Thank you for joining us for the first time today!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts.
This is important.
With the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
I'm happy that we're able to spend today this morning together with you.
Especially after the past few mornings being a little rough for FUWAMOCO.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
We have lots of things to talk about, Ruffians!
Are you ready?
Do you have your breakfast ready?
Coffee?
Tea ready?
Are you ready for disappointment?
Why disappointment, Moco-chan?
FUWAMOCO Morning!
We're live right now, what's disappointing, huh?
There's been another Pero Sighting.
What are we gonna do about that, huh?
Where was he seen this time, Moco-chan?
Let's take a look!
De-den!
Your fridge is empty now.
The only thing left inside, Ruffians, is no Pero.
It's disappointment.
That's basically Pero, huh?
Yeah, basically.
Basically, pao pao.
It even makes you feel any better!
The fridge kinda looks like ours now.
Yeah.
Yeah, matching fridges.
Yeah!
The only difference though is that our fridge has lots of tea and chikuwa in it and fish cakes.
My other one is sorta identical.
Identical fridges.
Yeah!
Yeah, but you know, that means Ruffians!
Grocery shopping!
Yeah!
And you know, we could just go together, right?
Grocery shopping with FUWAMOCO!
Yeah!
Lots of fun to experience!
Wow!
Yeah.
But make sure you know before you put the groceries in.
It's probably best that you clean Pero right out of there.
Yeah.
Otherwise you'll have to go grocery shopping again.
BAU BAU!
It's good to know it seems like Pero hasn't seen that much this week.
If you close the door then you don't see him again!
Lights out for you, Pero.
Because the lights go off when you close the fridge.
BAU BAU!
Wow, how weird!
There's been a little bit of an update, huh?
Update?
A little update?
Ruffians!
We did it!
FUWAMOCO!
Our big dream came true!
We reached 1 million!
1 million subscribers on YouTube!
Thank you so much for supporting us, Ruffians!
Thank you so much!
You know, whether you've been here from the very moment that we debuted, or maybe found us rather recently, or maybe even today, we're so happy to have you here by our sides and be able to protect your smile too!
It really means the world to us.
Everything.
And you know, we'll continue working like demon dogs here to make even more dreams come true!
To do even more cool and silly things!
And try things that we never thought we'd do!
And Ruffians!
We spent the moment that our dreams came true together with you!
Doing what we love most!
I'm protecting your smile!
That goes without saying.
But the very moment that we crossed into one million, FUWAMOCO we were singing our original song, Born to be BAU!
Oh, it was a miracle!
You just happened to wake up like that, huh?
Just right at the quiz!
Right!
BAU BAU!
Yo, thank you so much, Ruffians!
It was perfect, yeah!
Right!
You know, we know we have lots of goals and dreams, and hitting one million, that was a big one that we've always aimed towards since debut.
And you know, now that we've achieved this goal, our next big goal that we're aiming towards is to one day have our own FUWAMOCO solo live!
FUWAMOCO solo live!
Yeah, you know, but that kind of dream, having a solo live, it's something that almost every member of hololive dreams of.
So, FUWAMOCO, we're going to be very stubborn and work hard towards it so that maybe, one day, if it happens, that we can perform a bunch of our original songs!
Yeah!
Only to get better at singing, get better at dancing, and also get
More original songs, right?
Thank you.
So we're gonna work really hard, FUWAMOCO!
Please continue to cheer for FUWAMOCO!
Got it!
It's not gonna be an easy path, but let's do this!
Let's make this dream come true!
BAU BAU!
Have a day, you Ruffians!
I think there's some Ruffians that are still at 1 million celebration rates.
Soon.
Ish.
You surprised us Ruffians!
So you're gonna have to wait.
Soon.
Ish.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
I wouldn't worry for now.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's on.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, I'm sure you can...
FUWAMOCO Morning!
And now we've both been all kinds of under the weather!
But we've been doing our best!
It seems like it's likely the same cold that is generally going around right now.
I think there's a lot of senpai that are feeling a little bit the same as us.
But you know, we saw Moco-chan.
Moco-chan, you first lost your voice, right?
And I think there's a lot of Ruffians wondering, you know, while Moco-chan doesn't have her voice right now, what is it Fuwawa just stream on her own?
And that's a good question.
It's a good question!
But, well, if one of us gets sick, usually the other is not very far behind.
You know, we can tell.
And you know when Fuwawa did Fuwawa Week earlier in the year?
She could tell then, that she was okay.
I was okay.
But this time, it's not the same.
Not the same.
Yeah.
Sickness.
Is this how it is, you know?
But anyway!
I went to the doctor!
And I got an all okay!
As in, you know.
My barker is barking.
And my vocal chords are totally normal.
Weren't damaged, injured or anything.
No surgery needed, you know.
But it doesn't mean that
So I'll take the medicine I got, and I'll do my best to get better through the game!
FUWAMOCO, you know we'll do our best to take it as easy as possible.
We'll heal up, but please understand, you know, if we sound a little bit scratchy, or if maybe the schedule, our stream schedule has to be adjusted a little bit because of things.
Thank you for understanding.
We're doing our best!
But, you know, I think we're getting better slowly but surely here.
Slowly but surely.
BAU BAU!
We're hanging out with friends.
We're doing good.
Every night.
Fuwawa, we feel well today.
Don't we work hard?
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Moco-chan no onaka!
Hi!
Moco-chan's tummy!
It's a little prominent, right?
Like, prominent as in... I'm gonna poke it.
Why won't it poke it?
No.
You... You wouldn't do such a thing.
Bye.
I think Icomochi-mama was even suggesting something like that.
You win.
Just remember, Ruffians.
Don't touch the gas.
Don't touch the tail.
And don't touch the tongue.
BAU BAU!
But we really really can't wait until we meet you all as Ruffians!
In our FUWAMOCO we even ordered our full set too!
BAU BAU!
Now we can have all of us and everyone watching over us this year.
But it seems like there's been a lot of excitement at Shiori and Nerissa.
They've kind of even sold out currently on Geek Check.
You know, maybe for Ruffians.
Over in Europe and Australia.
So if you're planning to get an order of two Ruffians, please do so!
Check them out on the hololive official shop too, okay?
We will sell them too!
BAU BAU!
Please check them out, okay Ruffians?
And if you're interested, maybe... Yeah, they're still the official shop, okay?
They're still the official shop!
Today we stock...
Let's look forward to the announcement, okay?
We know that there is some talk about this extra silly, extra chaotic stream.
A very weird experience.
Yeah, we had a bit of a weird experience.
BAU BAU
Wow, FUWAMOCO, we participated in Mio-senpai's stream!
The Hoshou Marin's Brain Battle!
It was a weird experience.
But!
We are the loveliest, and fluffiest, and fuzziest version of Marin-senpai!
But you know, Ruffians, if you check it out, you can see just how chaotic and cursed the stream was.
Yeah, it was even close before it even started.
It was.
But you had, you know, FUWAMOCO we had the lovely Marin.
Yeah!
And then we had also Mio-senpai's gyaru Marin.
Subaru-senpai's passion Marin.
Okayu-senpai's sensitive Marin.
Fubuki-senpai's otaku Marin.
And Raiden as intelligent Marin.
Yeah, BAU BAU!
We did our best to solve Marine-senpai's biggest concerns, you know, like what she should stream or other concerns related to dating.
Love!
We did our best, you know, suggesting very lovely things.
But we got voted out right away by the Real Mighty.
Why?
BAU BAU!
Just cause you said Hunter Hunter isn't lovely.
Hi.
I think it's lovely okay.
I just thought that it wasn't lovely enough for you.
Only Marnie.
Bye bye.
But you know maybe that was the best because well things started to get very wild when the breaks you know FUWAMOCO.
Ra-den.
When they're taken away and then everybody
I lost it.
It went so really high.
You know, there's a mention of a mighty mist.
We skipped the dangerous smell and went right to the mist.
Yeah, it was a bit different.
Yeah.
It was a weird experience.
A little bit scary.
A bit like a Japanese battle.
But you know, it seems like we blew away everyone with our impersonations.
It's so fun!
Especially in English, you know?
I did my best to become English, Marnie.
You know, hololive English is 3rd generation.
What does that mean?
Morning senpai.
Advent.
Oh.
So if you didn't check it out, please go check out the stream over on Mio-senpai's channel!
Yeah, English writing was so good!
BAU BAU!
I'm glad!
You do the voice now!
It's gonna sound really funny, Ruffians, so no.
It sounds very nasally, huh?
Yeah, I think that was so Ruffian saying that I was pinching my nose, but no.
BAU BAU!
Thank you for meeting Ruffians!
We're FUWAMOCO-chan!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians go check out Mari's Brain Battle on Mio-senpai's channel!
Ruffians!
Did you see our big announcement in the middle of the night?
It's a big one!
Wow.
The other day, you know, we did an off co-op for the first time with the ASMR Goddess and also created our original introduction song, Lifetime Showtime style.
The very one and only SUPATORA!
Yeah, right!
Yeah, but last night, it was announced that FUWAMOCO will be releasing an ASMR voice pack directed, produced by SUPATORA!
BAU BAU!
Completely overseen all by her!
And recorded at her very own Patola Studio!
BAU BAU!
Patola Studio was amazing!
Ruffians, you made it!
Right!
I'm excited!
Looking forward to it!
Thank you for waiting!
As you know, it gets better because the voice pack will be on sale in only a few hours from now at 8pm PT or 12 noon GST.
You can find it on the official hololive shop for $4!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
So you can experience both FUWAMOCO in Oni and in English and Japanese too!
Look at the illustrations here all for you!
That means you'll have to look forward to what Moco-chan's way may be!
But it's super cute, right?
You might even want it as a
BAU BAU!
Thank you for waiting, Ruffians.
I think Moco-chan's corker is hurting a little bit.
BAU BAU.
But at the studio, we'll be doing a bunch of fun things together with Patra and Neza.
So if you're not able to watch live, please don't worry.
You'll be able to catch it all in the archive later.
But we're going to do our best to help you relax.
Ruffians, please let us know when the voice pack of our first ASMR goes on sale.
Please let us know what you think on Twitter.
And also the collab stream as well.
We're not gonna give you any hints.
We're recording it right now.
It has to be a mystery, okay?
But Ruffians, you can probably guess
Our hearts were beating really fast and it was really embarrassing.
BAU BAU!
Please take a little kiss!
I'm so excited!
We've been working really hard on FUWAMOCO and PANDORA-ONEESAN too!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, it's been a little while.
Can we take a look at our Doggie of the Day today?
Our Doggie of the Day is... Mochi!
BAU BAU!
Look at that!
Oh my gosh!
A big yawn?
What?
BAU BAU, she's just too cute!
That tummy, I just wanna stick my face in it.
BAU BAU!
Morning!
A very cute Doggie of the Day.
A doggy of the week?
Morning!
So cute, you can kinda see something on the tummy there.
Very cute.
Someone's homework.
I love how there's mochi.
BAU BAU, Moco-chan.
BAU BAU!
She's just too cute!
Mochi is mochi.
Mochi is a food.
I will eat mochi.
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look at what you've been going around on today!
And right on our mark, we have... De-den!
Did you get to see Haachama-senpai and Shiori at Anime Emporium?
Yes!
We're so happy!
Yeah, it sounds like... Well, if it's Shiori and Haachama-senpai together then...
I'm sure there was a lot of trouble that went on, huh?
A lot of chaos?
Things that can't be spoken of, maybe?
Maybe!
But we're so happy that you've been able to get out and have lots of fun at different conventions and hopefully also meet lots of different people!
And meet new friends too!
BAU BAU!
But Iron Impulse was so much fun when we went so we hope that we can be back again soon.
And next we have our Question of the Day!
We have De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
Have you ever thought about getting bunk beds again in the future?
Or do you feel content and comfy with just sleeping on your own beds distance from each other?
What do you think it is, Ruffians?
Well, I see.
It's definitely not a no.
Not a no.
You know, actually, well, recently especially we've been feeling like our beds, they're rather stiff.
They're pretty hard to lie.
We're both really surprised that the ground feels a lot more soft than our beds do.
We notice that when we go up there.
Why is that, huh?
Right.
But you know, it's okay because by the end of the day, we're so tired.
That's... That is amazing.
It's good!
Yeah, a good bed, so... You know, getting a new bed.
Maybe a bunk bed.
It's not a complete... No.
Not completely.
Yeah.
Not complete.
That's for sure.
But... Getting a new bed might be nice in the future but...
You thought we had a bunk bed still?
Sorry to break your jaws.
BAU BAU BAU!
We needed a bed for the doghouse and the bunk bed, but we'll get here very soon.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
Your Pero Sighting Doggy of a Day!
Sharing your walks with us and also sending us your questions!
We got so many great questions recently during our Marshmallow streams, so please send us more questions, Ruffians!
Please, when you send us a submission, don't forget to use the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
And we have our next stream coming up!
Very exciting one!
We have our 3D collab with Patra!
It's gonna be again at 3AM PT or 6AM ET.
Very nervous.
We're gonna do our best.
But it'll be a lot of fun with Patra Onee-san there.
She's gonna teach us a bunch of different things too, I'm sure, so... BAU BAU!
3D FUWAMOCO again, too!
BAU BAU!
And let's take a look at our schedule for this week!
Thank you, Ruffians, for understanding all the changes that have happened since we got sick.
Continue a little bit of the changes.
Well, this Sunday, instead of our Super Chat Reading at 6pm, we'll now be doing full lives together with the Doggy Pack then!
Thank you for waiting.
Doggy Pack I know has kind of changed a little bit there, but we will be doing a Super Chat Reading again in the future, so for Ruffians who are looking forward to that,
Don't worry, okay?
And!
Doggy Pack!
Mitsuhi got your four guys all ready.
Then you're ready to play!
And... Hopefully let us beat you.
BAU BAU!
Wow!
FUWAMOFUJUTSU are joining us to the archive today!
Here's your FUWAMOCO word!
It's BAU BAU ASMR!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much Ruffians for joining us today!
Not for understanding that FUWAMOCO is still a little bit under the weather.
We'll get through it really soon!
We're gonna have a bunch of fun tomorrow!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Yuukikaze anime!
BAU BAU!
Deathcorn!
Kitty!
BAU BAU!
Oppy!
Camomile!
BAU BAU!
Abyssal!
Taxi!
BAU BAU!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!